buckle your seatbelts and hold on tight
as we ramp up to 88 miles per hour and
break down the entire time traveling
adventure story of the Back to the
Future trilogy there's not a lot we know
about the original version of 1885
before Marty and dad started messing
with it but we do know one vitally
important event that happens Clara
Clayton was hired to be the new teacher
at the hill Valley School she had just
arrived at the Hill Valley train station
loaded up her wagon with her possessions
and was heading to her new home when a
snake spooked her horses and her horses
took off galloping towards show Nash
ravine after careening into the ravine
Laura died without ever making it to a
teaching post Clayton ravine wound up
being named after her and the story of
her death became an urban legend a Hell
Valley high every kid in school knows
that story cuz we all have teachers
would like to see fall into the ravine
in Hill Valley joined the fall of 1955 a
teenage George McFly is up in a tree
using a pair of binoculars to watch his
high school crush Lorraine Baines change
in a bedroom when he falls out into the
road and is hit by a car the driver of
the car turns out to be Lorraine's
father who not realizing that George was
peeping through his daughter's window
brings George into the house to
recuperate
Lorraine finds herself attracted to
George drawn by his apparent
helplessness and the two decide to
attend the enchantment under the sea
dance together where they kiss for the
first time
however Lorraine is also pursued by Biff
Tannen another teen in their high school
class who bullies George relentlessly
although the rain chooses George
Biff remains fixated on her and works to
make George's life more miserable as a
result on November 5th shortly before
Lorraine and George meet dr. Emmett Doc
Brown slips off his toilet or hanging a
clock bangs his head and is temporarily
knocked unconscious when he comes to
he's had a vision of an invention called
a flux capacitor which is what makes
Sloan trouble possible on November 12
the clock tower at the Hill Valley
Courthouse is struck by lightning
the original Back to the Future film
begins in 1985 where George and Lorraine
are now married and live in a modest
suburban home in Hill Valley that's work
George reports to Biff who continues to
bully him and creepily hit on Lorraine
instead of doing his homework George is
now graduated to doing best reports for
him
Lorraine's brother Joey is in jail and
has failed to make his parole for at
least the second time George and
Lorraine have three children
who's in his early 20s and works at
Burger King Linda who was around
nineteen and single and their youngest
Marty he was 17 and dreams of being a
rock star
[Music]
Marty's best friend is the eccentric
scientist of Braun and he has a serious
girlfriend named Jennifer a firm Marty's
mother doesn't approve Marty any girl
just asking for trouble
after 30 years of refining his initial
design dog finally perfects the flux
capacitor and built a time machine out
of a DeLorean because his invention
requires a huge amount of energy he lies
to a group of Libyan terrorists
promising that he'll build them a bomb
with the stolen plutonium they supply
and instead giving them a bomb casing
filled with pinball machine parts as
Doug conducts the first test of his time
machine at the Twin Pines mall the
terrorists arrive and shoot him dead in
an effort to escape from the terrorists
Marty jumps into the DeLorean and
accidentally travels back in time
arriving in 1955 Marty crashes into a
pine tree and winds up in a barn after
hiding the time machine Marty walks into
town when he sees a boy about to be hit
by a car and rushes to push him out of
the way the kites Marty instead and the
driver brings him inside the boy he
saved was his father and that instead of
becoming attracted to George Lorraine is
now attracted to Marty who goes by the
alias Calvin Klein determined to restore
the time line Marty seeks out the advice
of the 1955 version of doc who has just
had his vision of the flux capacitor doc
instructs him to do whatever he has to
do in order to get his parents together
before Marty's timeline is completely
erased from existence in the process
Marty's intervention gets George the
idea for a sci-fi novel Marty's plan to
push his parents together results in
George standing up to bear for the first
time and the newly confident George
finally kisses Laraine meanwhile Marty
gets chuck berry the idea to write the
song with Johnny be good three years
before the song was composed in the
original timeline Marty and Doc take
advantage of the Clocktower lightning
strike to create the power needed to run
the flux capacitor partisan the
Lightning so Marty can return to 1985
before Marty departs he writes doc a
letter warning him of his death in 1985
but dark rips a letter up saying that
the consequences of knowing his own
future could be disastrous
Marty decides to set the time of his
return to a few minutes earlier than he
left hoping he'll be able to save Doug
however by that
arrive to the mall now Lone Pine mall
thanks to the tree Marty crashed into in
1955 he's two legs and watch his dog get
shot again however after the terrorist
apart of Marty approaches Ducks body dog
sits up revealing that he's wearing a
bulletproof vest Stearns of Marty asks
how he knew duck admits he let his
curiosity get the best of him and tape
to Marty's letter back together
Marty returns home to find his family
significantly better off than he left
them George is now a published science
fiction novelist and he and Lorena
healthier and much more flirtatious than
they were in the original timeline while
they still live in the same house the
decors received an upgrade
although Marty's room remains the same
Biff now owns an auto shop and it's
responsible for the detailing on the
McFly casts instead of a Burger King
Dave now works in an office and while we
don't know much about Linda's life she's
at least dating Alice which seems to
speak to increase self-confidence
perhaps thanks for our own altered high
school dating experience the rain now
loves Jennifer and the McFly's have
purchased Marty a black pickup truck we
say expect him to take on his weekend
trip with her we never see what would
have happened in the original 2015
timeline before Marty traveled back to
1955 the first time and we actually
never get to learn exactly how things
play out in the first new timeline he
creates either the first perspective of
2015 that we get as ducks whose presence
in 2015 causes yet another timeline to
branch off however odds are that most of
this new timeline was very similar in
this timeline after graduating high
school marty was going to pursue a
career in music the finest rock star
dreams the Watts head due to a hand
injury sustained during a car accident
eventually Marty and Jennifer get
married in the chapel of love and have
two children Marlene and Marty jr. in
2015 Marty jr. agrees to help Biff's
grandson Griff Tannen robbed the Hill
Valley payroll substation he's
apprehended by police and sentenced to
15 years in prison
Marlene then attempts to break your
mouth and she is sentenced to 20 years
doc witnesses all of this during his
visit and takes a newspaper to help him
track alterations to the timeline he
also gets to hover conversion for the
DeLorean which allows the car to fly
replaces of the lorian's energy source
with a mr. fusion portable nuclear
reactor and puts his dog
Einstein into a suspended animation
kennel which honestly seems pretty risky
considering that he's about to reset the
whole timeline again
just as everything seems perfect for
Marty in 1985 duck returns from 2015 and
informs Marty and Jennifer that their
future children need their help the
three of them piled into the DeLorean
which could now fly thanks to his
alterations and zip back to 2015 the
spinning off a third alternate timeline
Bev sees them disappear but can't make
sense of what he saw for another 30
years in 2015
Jennifer is knocked unconscious for
Marty impersonates his son so he can
avoid the payroll robbery thus giving
both of his children a better fate
thanks to Marty's intervention Griffin
is Ganga rested instead feeling lucky
Marty purchases a gray sports Almanac
detailing the results of sporting events
from 1950 to 2000 but doc makes him
throw it away however recognizing the
flying DeLorean from 1985 a much older
Biff realizes it's a time machine
unbeknownst to Marty old Biff grabs a
sports Almanac and later steals a
DeLorean meanwhile Jennifer is brought
to her future home by well-meaning
police officers who believe she's a 2015
version of herself while hiding from a
future family she witnesses the older
Marty being fired by his boss after
agreeing to participate in an illegal
scheme with a co-worker
afterwards she reconnects with Marty and
duck and the trio plus Einstein who's
thankfully fine returned to 1985 old
Biff returns to November 1955 the same
day Marty originally traveled to in the
first movie he tracks down the teenage
Byford his grandmother's house and gives
the great sports Almanac to his younger
self instructing him to use it to place
bets on sporting events at first the
younger Biff is skeptical but old Biff
convinces him of the almanacs
authenticity by using it to predict the
results of a live event being reported
on the radio after convincing teenage
Biff of the almanacs potential power old
Biff instructs him to always keep it
hidden and locked up he also warns as
younger self that at some point in the
future a kid or a crazy wild-eyed old
man who claims to be a scientist may
show up asking about the book when that
happens old Biff tells young Bertha he
shouldn't hesitate to kill them old best
and takes a DeLorean and returns to 2015
leaving the Almanac with his younger
self not long after Biff uses a sports
Almanac to place his first bet and
quickly starts amassing a fortune
some time after Marty was born Biff now
a billionaire thanks
the Almanac kills George McFly and
marries Lorraine he also starts a
company called Biff Co uses as fast
resources and influence to legalize
gambling in California and builds
himself a 27-story casino in Hill Valley
named Biff's pleasure paradise this
control doesn't end with his businesses
though he also largely usurps control of
the hill Valley Police Department
leading to Hill Valley becoming a
teeming crime hub as fuller reins
children by 1985 dave has fallen into a
life of crime although Biff pays to keep
him out of jail Linda lives off of
bisque credit cards a marcia sent to
boarding school in Switzerland back in
Hill Valley Biff forces Lorraine to get
cosmetic surgery and she becomes an
alcoholic
hey bu yes it's me Marty are you all
right I'm fine
I'm fine it's just that you're so
yourself big this is a 1985 that Marty
and Doc returned to and which they
quickly realized that something in the
past has gone horribly wrong doc learns
at the 1985 D version of himself has
been committed to a mental hospital and
that George McFly is dead
Marty confronts Bev who readily admits
everything about the Almanac and his
killing of George and also tells him
exactly when he received the Almanac
from his future self
Biff then attempts to shoot Marty with
the same gun that killed his father
but Marty and Doc escape in the DeLorean
Marty and Doc travel back to 1955 to
steal the sports Almanac back from
younger Biff and restore the timeline
most events play out as they did in 1955
a since darker Marty have to be careful
not to allow the other versions of
themselves from the first movie no they
are there Marty manages to steal that
Almanac from Biff after George knocks
him unconscious but Biff later manages
to steal it back
finally marty is able to retrieve the
Almanac from this car while he's driving
it resulting in yet another car crash
ducky implores Marty to burn the Almanac
which he does using a matchbook had
taken from Beth's pleasure paradise in
1985 day as the Almanac burns the logo
on the matchbook changes into the one
for PIFS auto detailing business from
1985 a satisfied that they've restored
the timeline Marty and Doc prepare to
return to 1985
but before doc can van the DeLorean and
allow Marty to climb in the flying car
is struck by lightning and disappears
dark arrives in 1885 back in the
earliest day
of Hill Valley and finds at the time
circuits of the DeLorean have been
completely fried but a lightning strike
lacking the technology to fix a time
machine
duck realizes he's stranded in 1885 and
builds a new life for himself as a
blacksmith after spending some time in
1885 Doug decides to hide the DeLorean
in a mineshaft
and leave detailed instructions for
Marty and how to fix it in 1955 so he
can return to 1985 how could you
possibly know about it you sent me a
letter doc turn to letter over to the
Postal Service instructing them on the
exact location date and time that
they'll be able to deliver it to Marty
in 1955 in his letter he gives Marty
explicit instructions not to return for
him one of Doc's jobs as a blacksmith is
shoeing a horse for Buford Mad Dog
Tannen Biff's ancestor but Tannen then
refuses to pay afterward the horse
throws done enough causing him to break
a $5 bottle of whiskey Tannen blames
Doug for the incident saying he owes him
$5.00 for the whiskey and $75 for the
horse shortly thereafter doc is asked by
the mare to go meet the new
schoolteacher at the train station
leading him to save Clara Clayton from
her fall into the ravine the two quickly
fall in love but their romance is sadly
short-lived after getting his portrait
taken in front of the new courthouse
clock doc is shot in the back by Tannen
while dancing with Clara at the town
festival he dies and is buried in Hill
Valley where his grave is later
discovered by Marty in 1955 after
receiving Doc's letter after enlisting
the help of the 1955 earth dog to fix
her a covered century-old time machine
Marty travels back to 1885 despite Doc's
instructions however Marty nicks a fuel
line once he arrives in 1885 causing the
DeLorean to run out of gas
although doc challenges Marty's decision
to return for him Marty explains that
talk only has days left to live Dokka
Marty the latter of whom is now using
the alias Clint Eastwood again working
together to figure out a way to get the
DeLorean up to the required 88 miles per
hour without fuel will stop it here a
couple of cars from the tender throw the
switch track and then will hijack and
use it to put
the time machine aside from darker
Marty's attempts to get the time machine
working most events play out as they did
in 1885 F up until the town festival
when Marty saves Ducks life angry at
Marty's interference Mad Dog Tannen
challenges him to a duel in two days
time Marty and duck realized they have
to execute their plan to travel back to
the future before then and start
preparing to hijack a train
however doc becomes so despondent after
saying goodbye to Clara but he decides
he won't leave after all Marty yeah the
following morning a heartbroken Clara
buys a one-way train to get out of Hill
Valley while Marty is forced to face
Tannen after all using a trick from an
old Clint Eastwood western Marty manages
to survive and incapacitate Tannen and
he and Doug go to commandeer the train
not realizing that Clara is on board as
the train approaches 88 miles per hour
doc tusers to save Clara rather than
return to the future with Marty and as
the train soars off the track into the
ravine that the Lorien travels through
time again Marty returns home for good
to a timeline very much like the one had
hoped to restore with the exception that
the ravine is now named Eastwood ravine
after he supposedly perished in it in
the pasta he had just left
no sooner has Marty arrived back in 1985
than a modern train comes through
smashing the DeLorean to bits or marty
jumps to safety although it's
bittersweet marty realizes that this is
what doc wanted to have the
time-travelling be over the time line
secured marty back home and talked with
his true love
Marty reunites with Jennifer and the two
of them go for a drive they're
challenged to a race by Marty's future
criminal accomplice at a stoplight but
instead of racing Marty puts his truck
in reverse watching a Rolls Royce cuts
into the would-be path of his truck
marty realizes he would have gotten into
a devastating car accident which
Jennifer realizes as the accident that
would have cost him his music career
looking at the facts from 2015 scene
which Marty was fired Jennifer sees that
has been erased Marty and Jennifer head
back to the site of the wreck DeLorean
and a shocked when a flying locomotive
engine appears out of nowhere it turns
out that sometime after Marty traveled
back to the future doc stole another
train and built a new time machine which
he and Clara are using to travel
throughout time doc reveals a he and
Clara and now a
with two young sons Jules and Verne
after their favorite science fiction
author dark urges Marty and Jennifer to
make the best futures possible since
nothing has yet been written and then
takes off Ernest train for worlds and
times unknown check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the pal so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]